bonjour Christian Fontenette directeur
de l'agence réunion habitat nous sommes
situés au 50 rue du presbytère à
Saint-Pierre nous sommes une agence
immobilière nous effectuons de l'achat
de la vente de la location et de la
gestion nous rayonnons sur le secteur
sud notre métier d'agent immobilier
revête une connaissance particulière
tant sur le plan juridique que le plan
géographique sur lequel nous rayonnons
l'objectif de l'agence réunion habitat
au quotidien c'est de satisfaire nos
clients du démarrage jusqu'à la
définitif de vente effectivement acheter
un bien ce n'est pas anodin un
appartement un terrain une maison cet
ensemble revête un univers juridique
dans lequel nos clients attendent un
éclairage pour mieux comprendre et mieux
appréhender leur achat c'est pourquoi
l'ensemble de mes collaborateurs formés
et expérimentés pour appréhender ce
métier et le souci permanent que je me
donne pour réussir la mission que me
confie mes clients dans la vie de tous
les jours
aujourd'hui l'agence réunion habitat
fort de son développement recrute 10
postes de conseillers
en immobilier vente sur le tissu sud et
ouest de la réunion ce que j'attends de
vous demain qui allait intégrer mon
agence c'est d'avoir un état d'esprit
d'équipe soucieux d'un devoir
d'efficacité au quotidien
être professionnel c'est être connu et
reconnu sur son secteur intégrer
l'agence réunion habitat c'est réussir
son projet au quotidien bienvenue
évidemment je serai à vos côtés pour
mieux vous former mieux appréhender ce
métier de l'immobilier et ses
spécificités les mécanismes de la
transaction si vous vous reconnaissez
dans ce profil soyez les bienvenus à la
chanson